au palais de justice de vesoul c'est le
calme avant la tempête
une tempête médiatique avec ses vagues
de journalistes qui vont déferler au
milieu des autres procès pour la
présidente du tribunal judiciaire il a
fallu repenser toute l'organisation des
locaux
vous rentrez actuellement dans l'espace
d'assises spécialement agencé pour le
procès de johnatan navale qui débutera
donc lundi à 9 heures l'audience s'est
vu attribuer le label grand procès pour
cette petite juridiction c'est un
soutien logistique important du
ministère de la justice avocats famille
public et journalistes seront très
nombreux le nombre est un défi est
également les conditions sanitaires
extrêmement particulière de notre époque
il faut que l'on compose avec tout ça
avec une grande exigence à la fois sur
l'accueil qui doit être le meilleur
possible pour chacun et par ailleurs que
les journalistes puissent également
faire leur office puisque encore une
fois la justice est rendue
sous l'oeil du peuple français c'est
derrière cette porte que la cour
d'assises se réunir à la salle est en
cours de préparation impossible de
filmer
aucune caméra d'ailleurs ne sera admise
deux autres salles sont prévus pour
suivre le procès voici la salle b salle
correctionnelle qui va se permettre
d'accueillir une partie du public et une
partie des journalistes qui vont pouvoir
suivre le procès dont le contexte
sanitaire les places ont été divisés par
2 41 médias avec chacun un seul
journalistes ont été accrédités
on ne fera jamais aussi bien que dans la
salle d'audience à fait clair mais on a
réussi à obtenir par exemple le fait que
les grands bureaux transmission soit
divisé en 4 avec quatre images
différentes de la salle d'audience qui
permet d'être dans la salle de
retransmission un petit peu comme si on
était dans la salle d'audience à pouvoir
suivre plusieurs visages l'audience
devrait durer quatre à cinq jours à
suivre dès lundi